trans women and new Bud Light partner
Dylan Mulvaney now paid by Nike to model
sports sports bras okay on top of that
by the way by the way not only sports
bras Bud Light did you guys see the Bud
Light Video going viral and all this
stuff did you guys see him dancing with
the whole you know the Nike sports bra
stuff and then you got Kate Spade you
got Ultra Beauty you got a Crest
toothpaste and according to Newsweek
which we may be wrong but according to
Newsweek if you can pull this story up
according to Newsweek which this one
this is not Babylon B this is not onion
according to Newsweek he's about to be
sponsored by Tampax he is and apparently
based on this this Mulvaney guy
According to some of the Articles you
read about which is kind of deeply
concerning he's not fully committed he's
not a True Believer because he still has
a dangling which which kind of makes it
a little bit complicated because he's
not fully gone there okay do you realize
that every single day on my show and my
team is sitting right there I have to
live on air say the same thing could you
guys Google it does she have a dick and
the fact that I just said that in front
of Rudy Giuliani
who did it not a meme was before this I
lived in New York City during 9 11 like
this guy is a true hero and I apologize
for even doing that I don't know what a
meme is but I know what a dick is
laughs
[Music]
don't worry thank you good night
you let this descend to this bill
you thought you were gonna lighten the
mood a little bit there Pat Pat this you
realize you realize this is where you
were supposed to pull out a big machete
from under the desk and say which one
are you look I just thinking why do you
say that and everything because every
news every every news story these days
is about a former man now dressed as a
woman and we're always trying to figure
out have they gone the full way so for
example Rachel Levine who was a dude
dick Levine which is hilarious Rachel
Levine was Dick Levine you know that
yeah wow yeah his name was appropriate
his name was Dick he guys correct me
wrong he still has a dick yeah he still
has a dick yeah how do we but how do we
know that how do we know how do we know
I'm just kidding don't put the picture
on but every day there is another one of
these ridiculous stories where one of
these guys dressing as a girl and then
so it always to me it's like if you're
gonna actually you know Caitlyn Jenner
went all the way supposedly Caitlyn
Jenner no Wang really yeah wow
yeah so the fact that this keeps
happening over and over you know you
know it's crazy as much as obviously
we're joking about this there's a part
of this that's funny and we're having a
lot you know enjoying this part there's
a part of it that parents are sitting
there saying what the hell are we doing
like how the hell is this argument even
creating momentum where it's being
defended by the media and how dare you
say such a thing about them why
shouldn't they have the rights and all
this other stuff and your I saw a meme
the other day okay I know you're again
going back to memes can you just show
him a meme so we can please show me a
dick
yeah hey you know what I want you to do
Rob do me a favor and go to pbd podcast
Twitter account you are so we didn't
know you were a comedian mayor Giuliani
today comedy side so go to PPD podcast
Twitter account and I'm gonna text this
to you if you go on Twitter go to pbd
podcast I'll text the student go find
this wonderful meme it's not that I want
keep going over there it's not that one
keep going it's the one that says can
you drive a car can you do this it's a
day ago if you can find it I just texted
it to you there you go watch this one
here okay can you drive a car no can you
pick your bedtime no can you drink a
beer no can you vote no can you cut off
sex organs and take hormones yes
oh my God
I mean this is common sense stuff as
much as we're having you know we're
having fun with this this Mulvaney guy I
have a hard time saying this first time
because my son is his name it's a
wonderful name it's kind of confusing me
a little bit so you hear him sitting
down with you know Drew Barrymore and
she gets on her knees which is kind of
like a little you know weird situation
there but parents are worried it's
concerning okay they should be the the
Jew for a guy like it did you ever think
we're going to get to a point like this
where people who killed their dangling
are going out there promoting about the
fact that they're on the other side no I
I I didn't there was a candidate for
governor of uh North Carolina oh about
10 12 years ago so this goes way back
McCrory he's a great Governor 60
approval rating running for re-election
and the issue came up about bathrooms
you know they they the debate was
started in North Carolina about what
bathrooms to go into and he he wasn't
his good friend of mine and I said
that's easy you just do it based on
biology well he took that position he
lost by 10 in North Carolina
I mean and that was the beginning of
what the hell's going wrong and what's
going on what is
no I don't completely I have to admit I
do not completely understand what is
going on it seems to me it's obvious
there's a man and a woman we can figure
out who's a man and who's a woman and
why we're going through all this
I don't know if it's a site a mass
psychosis or it's a deliberate plot to
undermine us maybe it's both you know
what politician actually had the best
answer on this it's Donald Trump before
he was even a politician when he got
asked about this because you're right
this happened in North Carolina and then
the NBA was going to pull out an
All-Star Game in this whole thing and
they asked Trump when he was still just
Celebrity Apprentice Trump they said
what do you think about these trans
bathrooms he goes I'm a builder I build
hotels you tell me I can build one
bathroom I'm going to save on
construction
he he is
so Dave Chappelle has an amazing joke uh
uh on the LGBT have you heard this thing
on the closer he's like they're all in a
car ride together and you get the G the
G's driving because that's the white guy
it's a guy the G the L's sitting shotgun
right and everyone loves the elves but
except for the G's because they're all
they're kind of like I wouldn't wear
that whatever then you have the bees
you follow me here Rudy oh you're so far
you're gonna get the B and the bees in
the back just basically like I'll [__]
anyone in this car I don't care right
and then you got the T and the t is kind
of like making the whole ride go way
longer than it should it take yeah for
the G's the B's the L's because the t is
not anything like a g or an L or B it's
completely different and there's all
different parts going on different ways
so as a g yeah you
you're you're not anything close to T
well first off we just used like 40 of
the album I'm only gay starting at 10
p.m what time is it
it's 9 30. Rudy immediately checked his
watch we'll see about that
[Music]
look I
I did a gay wedding I mean you know
you lived you lived with two gay guys
dude I did I did absolutely that's more
that's one more gay guy
and they are they're wonderful parents
they're still married and they're
wonderful parents so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]